here is this lovely bag okay great cool
awesome
I will just pick one at random okay
great
by the way weird can we purchase this
bag it's on my website okay
just kidding it's my wife's make it back
okay cool this is from Andry salve
Jenko okay sorry I'm sorry I know I
butchered your name but I appreciate
your question hi what was the biggest
obstacle on your way in the whole
process and how were you able to get
through it
thank you Andy okay Oh Andrey up here oh
it might be a typo okay so it's Andy
Savchenko okay thank you for your
question oh thank you what's the biggest
obstacle on my way in the whole process
and how were you able to get through it
surprisingly I think like the at least
for me in my in my feature film I think
the biggest obstacle was really just
fear yeah and you know that's a very
like that might sound like a cop-out
answer but it's it's really not i think
the the hardest part is like trusting
yourself throughout the madness of
everything that's going on like the one
of the biggest fears i had was just like
trying to come up with the money for it
because that was a really difficult
process like we did a Kickstarter
campaign and we raised $35,000 for it
which was really I think I had a little
bit of beginner's luck because when I
look back at it now I kind of can't
believe that we did that it's pretty
wild but like I think that the hardest
part it's it's really the fear and also
the patience it takes to sort of do one
of these things because things are never
gonna move as fast as you want them to
move they're gonna move about like one
of the things I realized is like almost
everything that I thought I was yeah I
should have had done a month I just
started multiplying it by four so
everything like that's what we done in a
month and we take four months because
because working at this level because my
film is a micro budget film
you know it's basically like you know
there's a there's like a that triangle
right like the good fast and cheap
triangle you can only have two of them
that is a real thing that's totally a
real thing and so if you don't have the
money to do something and you are having
someone work on it like well they're
probably only gonna work on it like when
they have time to do so
and that means that you can get it good
but it's not gonna be fast and so like I
noticed that because like a lot of like
I think we we did like really really
great work on my film and the people
like all the different disciplines did a
great job but it just took a really long
time and I think that the patients can
almost be enough to drive you mad like
for instance our our our VFX guy who's a
brilliant VFX artist and he works at
like this big VFX house was basically
working on my film at nights every other
weekend because he had stuff to do when
he just had a brand-new kid and things
like that so like that took a long time
you know my my dear friend who's a sound
designer did sound on my film but he was
working on that throughout all all of
his different jobs so that was a super
slow process so I think just being
prepared with how with the patience like
how long it's gonna take
you'd be surprised like it like waiting
waiting for something can drive you mad
especially if like that is like your
number one focus which is which is your
feature or or your project that you're
working on because it's only gonna be
it's only gonna burn with that level of
intensity to you the creator it's not
gonna burn with that same level of
intensity or anybody else and knowing
that and embracing that can allow you to
be cool with it and like I think earlier
during the the post-production process
like I didn't understand that and that
would I would get angry and I would get
like very impatient and I would I would
be confused like why aren't they getting
back to me what's going on huh look I
can't take it you know and which is just
silly
you know because the reality is that
like anything that's that is good takes
time you know there's a I think the
quotes from like Alice in Wonderland but
there are no shortcuts to place is worth
going that's a real thing you know like
we live in a culture where we want
things we want it now and we want things
instantly but when it comes to making
something like like a feature or just
any sort of long-term project it just
takes time and takes time for the thing
to to develop it takes time for the
thing to marinate and the patience and
getting through the fear of it are the
two biggest obstacles I'd say
you